foreign
[Music]
welcome to shoe manufacturing 101 so
before we dive into what is our latest
technology to cap the air put into the
shoe so I think we have to align our
understanding about the shoe first so I
think everyone just like uh maybe every
day or maybe every week you will go to
your shop and maybe you look at it about
the what is the latest shoe and actually
every day all brands they just try to
put a new shoe new model of shoes to you
to say hey come and buy me so right now
in the world we have a lot of shoes but
actually in the shoes do we really
understand the shoe actually there is
like four very important element to have
to make one shoes so first the parts
like lens the tongue and the other
decoration things and second the upper
Opera is the most important one because
the Opera make you to do the final
decision so if you think you like the
the design then you buy it and the one
before you make the final decision is
the missile because it's the soul of the
athletic shoes so if you want jump
higher you won't run faster you won't
have a very stable performance in the
gym then you will feel how missile to
kind of like give you the feedback and
then the last one is the outsole so my
company can still is the machine company
we design a machine to produce the
missile the soul of a shoe so because
these shoes you know it's kind of like
we so far it's kind of like a chemical
fins so those Brands and their suppliers
put a lot of different kind of Integra
ingredient ingredients to put in the
middle so it becomes a very huge
challenge because everything on the shoe
is very soft so it it's almost impo
impossible to make it automation to do
the production so that's the whole
reason why they put the whole shoe
industry in the Asia I know most of you
already know that from Korea to Taiwan
China and the whole Southeast southeast
Asia and also the south Asia so but
during the covid-19 those plants already
feel something they have to change
because all of the interruption make
them very very difficult to gain the
stocks over you know a lot of supply
chain issues so right now all of the
brands they just think about how to
prove the production line back to the
market and they can supply fast and they
can supply it on a very good price so
this is the first thing and also because
the climate change and because of the so
is dying so this comes another very big
problem right now in the world so which
is
every year every year there are 23
billion shoes is made every year and
then 22 billion shoes
are disposed every year so most of
Brands they try to do the recycling but
it's so difficult because as I mentioned
it's a chemical fence it's very
important very impossible to do that
things so all that they can do is put
into the landfill so right now I think
we understand that we have less and less
the land to do things like that so all
of the prints they just think about how
to do it so because we solve these two
problems Automation and how to do the
recycling so that's the reason why we
just come up with a very new technology
and we call it an Excel
okay
okay request access anyway next sale is
the technology we just captured the air
it's there is like 70 percent of
nitrogen in the air we just breathe it
every day so we just lock we just
captured those air and then we put into
our machine then we inject into the
missile so that will help us that we
will not change the material itself so
the prints they can just recycle from
you and then cut into small pieces and
we can recycle it again then maybe we
can put back into the shoe or maybe we
can put into another kind of products so
this is the technology right now we just
try to launch into the world so this
next sale is a product it is a concept
that technology that we can say is 100
for recycling 100 for reusable and also
100 for automation so uh
it's not that easy you know for we for
King steel we try to develop this
technology it's not that easy actually
we spent like 10 years from the zero to
the one so I would like to share some
stories behind that Innovation Journey
so first of all right mindset is very
important no shortcut where every time
we do the Innovation sometimes we just
think about is there any easy way to do
it is there anything that we can just
put them together then we can count up
something new but actually the answer is
no because every time if we think about
the shortcut which means we will start
to miss very important thought behind
the information so Kingsdale when we
start to do this technology actually we
try to buy some technology from its
developed in MIT so just try to bring
that technology into our machine and we
think okay maybe in one or two years
then bam we can have the technology
however we failed we try it like three
years however we got nothing so at that
moment the whole company we just
realized one thing that there is no
shortcut we have go back to the very
beginning and to make sure that we
really understand what we are trying to
do so
on the way to the to next sale we find
out a lot of failure and but the good
thing is we try to connect every failure
to see what's going on behind the whole
technology and what is the mechanism
and second positive atmosphere team
motivation this is very important
because think about it we start the
project from 2009 and then then we
launched it in 2020. so it's around it's
just about 10 years it's a very long
journey so how can you make sure that
everyone in the team still want to stay
there and want to do something new and
they want to be there with you it's so
difficult it's a challenge and even as a
leader we just stand there and tell
everyone hey follow me please follow me
sometimes they will feel like anxious
and sometimes they will feel very
frustrated so the best thing is we have
to make sure that everyone they can kind
of like Inspire each other so we are not
just the only one in the team try to
inspire our team but we try to encourage
others to inspire others so let's see
what's different and even it's a failure
that's unders let's try to understand
what is the value what make this value
and if we got one percent Improvement
then we just think about how can we do
that one percent Improvement to two
percent or to ten percent so even we
just like you know we need another 100
days to get 100 or we need another 100
months to get that 100 perfect we don't
know but at least we start from this we
start from here so every day if we have
the chance to talk with someone in the
team or in the whole organization we
have to create the positive atmosphere
to make sure that everyone can motivate
others
and the third transparent engagement
that will help us to get the proactive
partnership because sometimes in Asia we
try to hide our technology because we're
afraid to be copied or reverse reverse
engineering from others but if we don't
share the information if we don't share
the ideas then it's so difficult for
each other to communicate just like Yoda
said it's the B side it's impossible so
be transparent just share the technology
with your partners then they will
understand and the most important thing
is they will trust you once they start
to they start to trust you then it will
start they will become your proactive
partner they will start to help you to
share your ideas they will help you to
promote your technology they will help
you to bring everyone together in the
room and make sure that this is
something we want and we want to pump
this into the market
so uh capture the air is a technology
about how we capture the air and put
into the missile but also the most
important thing is sometimes Innovation
just like a notion idea in the air and
we just try to catch it and then bring
it to the ground and make sure that this
is something real
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]